[Music]
with one spin-off underway and another
in the queue yellowstone is showing no
signs of slowing down when it comes to
keeping viewers coming back or tuning in
for the first time week after week
without a doubt a major component of the
serious appeal is its most rugged
anti-hero rip wheeler whose devotion to
john dutton and yellowstone ranch
appears to know no bounds and yet there
are bounds when it comes to what
audiences are willing to accept with
regard to the often criminal inevitably
violent actions rip feels he must take
in order to defend the duttons and their
ranch throughout season 4 another
beloved character lloyd pierce has
butted heads with one of the other ranch
hands walker walker stole lloyd's
girlfriend and lloyd has been unable to
keep his jealousy and anger at bay ever
since after lloyd breaks the no fighting
in the bunkhouse rule in episode 4 rip
and john ultimately decide the two
should work their issues out by pounding
the crap out of one another though jon
has one more wrinkle to add
i want you to make an example out of
last man standing
rip not only pummels lloyd repeatedly in
episode 4 after the latter's initial
fight with walker but he also beats him
down aggressively in episode 6 and
graphically smashes lloyd's hand with
his boot lloyd's second beating
importantly isn't rip's way of
reiterating this
no fighting on this ranch you want to
fight somebody you come fight me i'll
fight you all day
when rip destroys his best friend's hand
it's because lloyd refuses to back down
from a fight that john dutton ordered
rip to have lloyd and walker undertake
until they could work out their issues
by the time rip nobly shoulders the
burden of taking lloyd down for good
lloyd's been continually fist fighting
with walker for well over an hour prior
to the premiere of season 4 fans were
already speculating about rip and
lloyd's fight from the trailers and had
some pretty distinct opinions about what
they felt it would take to justify such
a thing as one fan wrote on the series
subreddit lloyd would have to commit a
cardinal sin for rip to beat him up
lloyd's cardinal sin on the surface was
stabbing walker scratch below that
surface however and it becomes clear
that his real sin was putting his own
personal grudge against walker over the
safety of the ranch or so we're told
however it's a bit more complicated than
that as viewers will recall casey was
supposed to kill walker in season 2
after the singer saw rip help jaime
cover up a murder casey however couldn't
bring himself to killwalker and misstep
rip and lloyd discover in season 3
episode 9 but walker doesn't actually
return to the yellowstone ranch on his
own walker shows up in dillon had lloyd
and rip simply walked away from the bar
and pretended they never saw walker they
wouldn't be obligated to keep him under
the thumb of the ranch at all since he
clearly wasn't interested in reporting
anything he saw to the authorities
thus the better part of the situation
that leads to rip being forced to beat
down on lloyd is a situation largely of
his own making and subsequently
difficult to chalk up to just another
instance of cowboy justice add to that
the fact that walker and lloyd's entire
conflict does little if anything to
further the plot of the series and you
have the makings of a scene that simply
crosses one bridge to many when it comes
to anti-heroes like rip audiences can
accept otherwise unacceptable levels of
violence since they're tethered to the
narrative these acts would be appalling
to our sense of right and wrong in the
real world but within the fictitious
universe they can be justifiable it's
only when that violence spills outside
the bounds of that justification either
because we've gained too much sympathy
for the individual on the receiving end
or because it doesn't come off as a
legitimately necessary action that our
willful suspension of real-world
morality begins to break down
viewers not only have enormous amounts
of sympathy for lloyd but it's also
difficult to understand the thinking
that went into throwing two ranch hands
and integral employees into a
gladiator-style fight to the finish only
to then punish one of those individuals
for doing exactly what he was told it's
so difficult to understand in fact that
several viewers on one reddit red
theorize that the scene only really
existed because the show is setting up a
situation for rip to take lloyd for
granted and then realize he was wrong
whether that theory pans out or not
we'll just have to wait and see check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
yellowstone are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you